Speaker 1: Welcome to the show. Let's start with
the latest updates from the January 6th committee.
This is different than the January 6th
commission. Remember, the commission was
going to be this big bipartisan commission to
investigate the Trump riots, which would include
five Republicans chosen by Republicans and
five Democrats chosen by Democrats who'd have
a Democratic chair and a Republican vice chair.
And they'd have to sign off on every subpoena. And
it was all going to be great, except Republicans
said no, no, no, because they wanted it to include
looking into things like when Steve Scalise was
shot in, I think it was 2017 and the George Floyd
protests and things that really had nothing to
do with the Trump riots. So that didn't happen.
And eventually we got the committee that had four
police officers, Capitol Police officers testify
about a month ago and it's now continuing
to move forward. And the new battle lines
on this appear to be requests for documents from
Donald Trump. And Donald Trump is panicking and
Donald Trump is desperate to hide those
documents. Former President Donald Trump
has called the select committee investigating
the January six capitol riot a partizan shame.
Remember that it is what it is because
Republicans refuse to participate in the
original big commission and suggested that he will
invoke executive privilege as the committee seeks
a trove of documents. Trump issued a statement on
Wednesday slamming the leftist committee after it
sent its first request for documents relating to
the events of January 6th. These requests included
communications with, within and among the White
House and executive branch agencies. The committee
is chaired by Democratic Representative Bennie
Thompson and includes Republican Representatives
Liz Cheney and Adam Kinzinger. Both critics of
the former president. Trump's statement said
the leftist select committee has further exposed
itself as a partizan sham and waste of taxpayer
dollars, with a request that's timed to distract
Americans from historic and global catastrophes
brought on by the failures of Joe Biden and
the Democrats. Unfortunately, this partizan
exercise is being performed at the expense of
long standing legal principles of privilege.
Executive privilege will be defended not just
on my behalf, on behalf of my administration
and the Patriots who worked beside me, but
on behalf of the office of the President
of the United States and the future of our
nation. Everything's delusions of grandeur.
These Democrats only have one tired trick
political theater, and their latest request only
reinforces the pathetic reality. So the reading
here is Trump is desperate, desperate not to have
any documents related to him or his administration
presented to the committee. Now, he may well
succeed or at least tie this up in court long
enough that it goes absolutely nowhere. And that's
that's disturbing. More on this from CNN,
which wrote, The Biden administration has
already declined to assert executive privilege
over some testimony related to January six,
telling former Justice Department officials they
were free to provide unrestricted testimony.
But the administration has not weighed in on
whether the committee should have unrestricted
access to records and documents from the Trump
White House. The document requests from the House
Select Committee echo those previously issued
by other House committees in the aftermath
of the January 6th riot, while significantly
broadening the search to other areas and people
inside and outside government. Specifically,
the select committee is asking for records
from the Department of Justice, Interior, Defense
Office of the Director of National Intelligence,
FBI, National Counterterrorism Center, Department
of Homeland Security and perhaps most importantly,
the National Archives, the custodian of the
Trump administration. White House records. Now,
as has been the case with Donald Trump for years,
if you really believed you were not guilty of what
you're being accused or suspected, you would
want documents to come out, which would prove
your innocence. If you believe you've done
nothing wrong when it comes to your taxes,
you would want, given all of the ways in which
not releasing your taxes has dragged you down, you
would want it to come out that everything's fine
with your taxes. This is fundamentally not the way
an innocent person behaves. And unfortunately,
because of the way things have gone and I know
every time I'm real with the with the audience,
somebody gets mad and says, David, you're
you're not you're you're you should be telling us
it's all going to happen. I think there's a really
good chance that Donald Trump prevents these
documents from being presented to the committee
or delays it long enough that it won't
matter or makes it so that they're they are
redacted documents or whatever the case may be. I
unfortunately think that it's completely plausible
that that may be the way that it goes. So
we're going to continue covering the January
6th committee if there are committee events
and test. Money that you think I should cover,
I may miss it, I'm trying to keep an eye on a
lot of different scheduling things, Biden stuff,
Trump stuff, hearings, all these different
things. Feel free to shoot an email to
info at David Pakman Dotcom. When the four police
officers testified, it was very informative and
very illuminating and worth worth covering
live. So let me know if you see any of that.